welche werbung du siehst welchen preis
du bezahlst welche filme die ihr
vorgeschlagen werden und sogar mit wem
du auf das nächste date gehst wird
heutzutage alles von künstlicher
intelligenz beeinflusst den begriff
haben sicherlich alle schon mal gehört
denn das thema wird gerade zu recht oder
zu unrecht ohne ende gehabt und trotzdem
wissen viele gar nicht was dort
eigentlich genau passiert
wie funktioniert so ein algorithmus der
scheinbar alles lernen kann
[Musik]
der begriff künstliche intelligenz ist
etwas dramatisch und
populärwissenschaftlich stattdessen
sprechen experten eher von machine
learning dem lernen der maschinen
aber wie funktioniert das eigentlich wie
kann ein computer denn nur mit einzeln
und nullen arbeitet etwas lernen wenn
ich euch frage welches dieser beiden
bilder einen menschen zeigt dann stellt
das hoffentlich kein problem für euch da
auch verwischte verdeckte oder
versteckte menschen können wir meist
ohne probleme erkennen und selbst ein
neuartiges konzept dass ihr vielleicht
noch nie zuvor gesehen habt könnt ihr
innerhalb von sekunden verinnerlichen
und wiedererkennen ohne dass ich euch
sagen muss welche eigenschaften diese
spezielle konzept ausmachen
aber wenn es darum geht zu erklären wie
wir etwas wiedererkennen können haben
wir keine ahnung wie lernen wir nun
natürlich muss das lernen irgendwo im
gehirn stattfinden und deswegen auch
irgendwie mit den neuronen und synapsen
in unserem gehirn zusammenhängen
aber während wir noch verstehen wie ein
einzelnes neuron funktioniert ist es
beinahe unmöglich vorherzusagen wie ein
großer haufen neuronen zusammenarbeitet
mein ansatz des maschinellen lernens
sind die sogenannte neuronale netze die
idee der neuronalen netzes lose davon
inspiriert wie man sich auch vielleicht
vorstellt wie das menschliche gehirn
arbeitet das ist doktor jascha ulrich
der bei zeit in der aktiven forschung an
maschinen learning arbeitet und ich habe
ihn gebeten mir einmal so einfach wie
möglich zu erklären was ein neuronales
netzwerk ist ganz schön wie möglich zu
sagen einen also neuronales netzwerk
dazu braucht erstmal neuron ja und dann
hast du ein einzelnes neuron
das ist ganz simpel das kriegt eingabe
signal und da kommt was raus und das
kann das eingabe signal
vielleicht verändern in sehr begrenzten
maßstab aber das macht ihn sehr sehr
begrenzten maßstab und mit einem neuen
was 1 1 gab signal kommt und was raus
schick kann ich noch nicht viel anfangen
und jetzt kann ich mir überlegen ich
mache jetzt ein ganz großes netzwerk von
all diesen neuronen und dann kann ich
versuchen einfach schon etwas viel viel
komplexeres zu realisieren
mit ganz vielen kleinen bestandteilen
die halt einfach alle nur etwas sehr
sinnvolles machen um sich das besser
veranschaulichen zu können bauen wir
jetzt einmal unser eigenes neuronales
netzwerk sagen wir wir wollen es dazu
bringen das ist menschliche gesichter
erkennen
unser netzwerk ist zu beginn nichts
anderes als ein computerprogramm das
einzelne knotenpunkte simuliert diese
knotenpunkte nennt man auch wirklich
neuronen und ein neuron hat hier nur
eine aufgabe eine zahl entgegenzunehmen
diese auf eine bestimmte art und weise
zu verarbeiten und dieses ergebnis
auszugeben
eine neuerung kann zum beispiel die
aufgabe haben jede zahl die es erhält zu
halbieren
unser netzwerk ist außerdem in schichten
aufgeteilt und so aufgebaut dass die
werte der einen schicht zur nächsten
schicht weitergegeben werden bis am ende
nur zwei neuronen die werte
entgegennehmen
diese beiden neuronen stehen für gesicht
und kein gesicht und sind am ende unser
ergebnis wenn alles richtig läuft dann
sollte einer dieser beiden punkte einen
möglichst hohen wert erhalten wenn man
vorne in das netzwerk ein bild einspeist
da wir aber mit kommt der zufällig
generierten werten staaten kommt jetzt
erstmal natürlich nur quatsch raus das
netzwerk ist totales chaos und ergibt
keinen sinn
und das ist auch in ordnung da wir
selber gar keine vorgabe machen wollen
wie das netzwerk arbeiten soll
nun kommt der interessante teil der teil
in dem unser netzwerk etwas lernt ein
neuronales netzwerk ist nämlich quasi
eine mathematische formel und indem wir
die einzelnen variablen dieser formel
die neuronen verändern lernst das
netzwerk wenn wir ein bild in unser
netzwerk einspeisen und wie erwartet
eine zufällige mischung aus unseren
beiden antwortmöglichkeiten erhalten
können wir die netzwerk einen schubs in
die richtige richtung geben
wir wissen dass das bild ein
menschliches gesicht enthält und wollen
also dass am ende das neuronen gesicht
einen möglichst hohen und das neuronen
kein gesicht einen möglichst kleinen
wert hat um das zu erreichen können wie
die verbindungen zu diesen neuronen
beeinflussen indem wir die werte der
neuronen in der schicht davor verändern
und um diese werte zu ändern müssen wir
die werte in der schicht davor verändern
da in unserem netzwerk alles miteinander
verbunden ist spielt jeder einzelne wert
eine rolle und verändert das endergebnis
nachdem wir nun das erste bild
eingespeist und das netzwerk ein kleines
bisschen angepasst haben kommt das
zweite bild und dann das dritte und so
weiter bei jedem einzelnen bild dass wir
ins netzwerk werfen schauen wir uns das
ergebnis an und justieren die vielen
hunderttausend oder sogar millionen
stellschrauben so dass das ergebnis ein
kleines bisschen mehr in
die richtung geht die wir erreichen
wollen je nach aufgabe braucht man
millionen trainings bilder von denen
jedes einzelne vorher von einem menschen
markiert werden muss das sind eine menge
daten aber es lohnt sich denn wie durch
magie kann unser netzwerk aus
abermillionen stellschrauben die jetzt
bilder mit gesichtern von bildern ohne
gesicht unterscheiden
wichtig für das verständnis ist dass wir
dem netzwerk keine konkrete aussage
gegeben haben
wir haben nicht gesagt dass ein gesicht
immer zwei augen eine nase und einen
mund hat so lernen wir als kinder
nämlich auch nicht was ein gesicht ist
stattdessen findet das netzwerk
sozusagen seine eigene methode
man könnte vermuten dass die ersten
geschichten des netzwerks dazu da sind
kanten und muster zu erkennen während
die schichten dahinter augen und nasen
erkennen können aber wenn man in ein
solches neuronales netzwerk hinein guckt
sieht der arbeitsprozess für uns
menschen immer noch extrem zufällig aus
das ist das spannende an carey selbst
die programmierer der algorithmen selber
wissen nicht genau warum die algorithmen
arbeiten wie sie es tun und trotzdem
funktionieren sie oft mit über 99
prozent genauigkeit
wer jetzt angst davor bekommt dass ein
solches neuronales netzwerk ein
bewusstsein entwickelt und immer
intelligenter wird um schließlich die
menschheit zu unterjochen der täuscht
sich
wer ein neuronales netzwerk ist
natürlich inspiriert durch ein
menschliches gehören
aber natürlich ist ein neuronales
netzwerk kein selbstständig denkendes
wesen sondern letztendlich ist es nur
eine mathematische funktionen die zu
einem gegebenen input einen festen
output berechnet genau es ist nichts
anderes als eine unglaublich
komplizierte matheformeln und trotzdem
verändert machine learning unser leben
algorithmen können inzwischen brett und
computerspiele besser spielen als die
jeweiligen weltmeister sie können neue
bilder und videos kreieren die täuschend
echt aussehen und somit kreative neue
möglichkeiten eröffnen und sie retten
menschenleben malaria tötet jedes jahr
eine halbe million menschen die hälfte
der menschheit läuft gefahr sich mit
malaria zu infizieren um medizin
resistente version der krankheit zu
erkennen müssen ausgebildete experten
zirka 20 minuten lang
einem mikroskop eine blutprobe
untersuchen und das für jeden patienten
aufs neue
deswegen haben forscher nun ein
neuronales netzwerk darauf trainiert die
malaria parasiten unter dem mikroskop zu
erkennen
dabei ist der algorithmus inzwischen
genau so akkurat wie ein gut
ausgebildeter arzt im labor
falls sich das netzwerk dennoch unsicher
ist schaut sich ein mensch die blutprobe
an und ich denke so oder so ähnlich
sieht unser zukünftiges zusammenleben
mit künstlicher intelligenz aus arbeit
die wir menschen nicht machen können
oder wollen geben wir an algorithmen ab
und falls dort ein problem auftauchen
sollte dann schauen wir menschen drauf
mit unseren biologischen neuronalen
netzwerk doktor jascha ullrich habe ich
übrigens auf der auftaktveranstaltung
2018 von zeiss interviewen können
es hat mich netterweise bei der
produktion dieses videos unterstützt und
eingeladen um in oberkochen dabei zu
sein als derzeit mit ward an schüler
auszubildende und studenten vergeben
wurde
bei dem wettbewerb hatten die teilnehmer
die möglichkeit ihre eigenen
wissenschaftsprojekte vorzustellen von
selbstfahrenden autos bis zu helfer
robotern waren alle möglichen coolen
projekte vertreten
vielen dank an zeit für die
unterstützung und danke an euch fürs
zuschauen bleibt neugierig war cedric